dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire les
entreprises aussi s'engage à le mettre
leur expertise et leur savoir-faire pour
la lutte contre ce coronavirus bonjour
nicolas landry ce bonjour la rédaction
de tv 60,18 vous parlais justement de ce
sujet avec votre invité est
effectivement dagory avec nous au
grégory agnès bedot bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes senior vice president le
responsable des activités high
performance computing and friendship
chez atos donc c'est les
supercalculateurs et l'informatique
quantique d'atos vous travaillez sur le
site des clayes-sous-bois sur ces sujets
là alors comment les technologies
développées par atos participent à la
lutte contre le colis 19
les supercalculateurs sont au coeur de
la recherche scientifique française et
mondiale
elle est super créateurs que l'on
fournit chez atos ont conçu et développé
par les équipes de r&d des quais sous
bois c'est un travail de fond qui après
18 mois de recherche et développement
aboutissent à la fourniture et et
allahou développement et la mise sur le
marché de supercalculateurs donc on a ce
type de supercalculateur qui sont
installés sur les plus grands centres de
calcul européens et mondiaux alors
qu'ils utilisent ces outils et pour quoi
faire
les grands centres de recherche
académiques les les les centres de
calcul et de simulation numérique des
grandes entreprises dans différents
domaines que ça soit la recherche
pharmaceutique de la recherche
académique et différents domaines à de
simulation numérique est typiquement
dans le cadre actuel de la recherche sur
le gobie de 19 les grands centres de
recherche nationaux vont mener des
études autour de la simulation numérique
qui a à voir avec différents sujets
typiquement des recherches
épidémiologiques pour le virus était
recherche de nouvelles molécules pour
pouvoir ensuite apporté des vaccins sur
le marché et ce genre de calcul
fondamentaux qui permettent en analyse
chimique et biologique d'apporter des
solutions
dix sont des supercalculateurs développé
sur le site des clayes-sous-bois est-ce
que lorsque les collaborateurs d'atos
développent ce type d'outil y pense à
ces sujets là justement que ça peut
servir dans une crise exceptionnelle
comme on la vit aujourd'hui c'est notre
adn de fournir à des supercalculateurs
pour apporter des solutions aux
industriels et aux organismes de
recherche
quand on parle de deux pandémies bien
sûr c'est un sujet lancement même si ce
n'est pas un sujet qui est forcément
dans la tête de tout le monde et qui ne
l'était pas avant la situation qu'on vit
19 je dirais mais apporter des solutions
des vaccins de la recherche pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique ou pour tout
simplement les hôpitaux de la recherche
sur la génomique etc
ça fait partie de la même manière que la
recherche sur laquelle le climat où ce
genre de deux thématiques les
supercalculateurs sont absolument des
points d'entrée de recherche mieux sur
la simulation numérique et pour apporter
des outils ou pays aux institutions et
aux à la population j'ai comme en les
collaborateurs ont développé ces
supercalculateurs faut préciser que les
supercalculateurs sur des gros
ordinateurs en fait finalement avec des
puissances de calcul assez importante et
tout à fait les calculs et les
supercalculateurs c'est tout simplement
la mise en å parallèle de milliers de
calculateurs enfin de pc individuelle et
qui vous constituerez constituer ce
qu'on appelle une ferme de calcul fait
de de milliers et de centaines de
milliers de de puissance de calcul
additionner les ans loos a fabriqué en
fabrique un supercalculateur avec une
réseau d'interprétation rapide et au
lieu de faire un traitement sur une
machine et apc et comme chez vous vous
faites à un traitement numérique en
parallèle sur des milliers de données ce
qui vous permet d'accélérer et de faire
du par des coupes yachting un dernier
mot avec vous à des bouts d'os
on va le voir sur ces images dans le
site r&d des clés souvent est en cours
de construction ça sera un site r&d qui
réfléchira sur l'informatique quantique
en quoi cette informatique quantique
déjà vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que
c'est en quoi il permettra peut-être de
trouver plus rapidement plus facilement
un vaccin contre les virus contre les
pandémies et puis faire d'autres choses
de manière plus rapide
j'ai envie des cantiques et les super
recul elle est super calculateur
quantique sans sont vraiment l'avenir
néanmoins on est déjà au coeur du sujet
effectivement avec les équipes des
caisses du bois et de r&d puisqu'on
travaille d'ores et déjà et nous avons
mis à disposition un simulateur
quantique et l'idée c'est de pouvoir
travailler sur des algorithmes et des
problématiques que l'on ne sait pas
résoudre aujourd'hui avec les
supercalculateurs classique donc
l'objectif c'est de traiter plus
rapidement via des technologies
nouvelles et des algorithmes avec
l'informatique quantique des d'accélérer
la recherche et d'être effectivement
idéalement capacité d'aller plus vite
même de réduire un temps vraiment très
court à certaines recherches qui
prennent énormément de temps au menu
merci année ce bout d'os pour ses
explications
merci